was so full podcast happy new year
everyone we're back yeah 2018 Rodrigo
toys right here chillin with cracking
down Lisa went away for a while look for
the hole with our guest the wheel to
steal the engineers over here chillin
dig in what's up fool crack ho noise
right there man what up popping those
way man I really broke my new year
resolution what happened
sorry smoking weed again but it'll weed
from last year so it'll really count
psych psych hell yeah man two upcoming
shows tonight we're at Boulder Colorado
at the boulder theater January 5th today
man tomorrow Saturday we're in Portland
Oregon and Revolution Hall haven't been
there in years
mama Kiki and next week January 12
sold-out Chicago Illinois it's all sold
out for the big the shy dog yeah madam I
had another song you never know
everybody's asking for tickets already
talking about I met you in Austin
January 13th New York City at the
PlayStation Theatre New York baby papa
we're coming is Rodrigo Torres I think
Toby Hicks me and Martin R is over there
looking for victims everywhere so I'm
talking about this kid one doc Palm
Springs Coachella California spotlight
29 January 20th get your tickets man
they show it's gonna sell out January 27
to senators own ad Sawa Rita Arizona at
desert diamond casino in February I'm
coming back to Naples Florida brawl
captain Brian dr. Brian and his cool ass
family man love the guy after hook
comedy club also I'm coming to the tachi
casino it's in Fresno okay
Tachi casino right after Tosha Kristina
where'd you go I don't know what we're
gonna get a flight but we're gonna go to
bigger the next day and
the Treasure Island casino for one night
man we were gonna put either a day
before but then the Fresno gang shut up
right so now we are gonna spend in one
night
the following night bro right after that
show we're going to do a show in
Washington Rochester Washington at the
lucky ego casino anybody in that area
we're gonna be a lucky ego casino lots
more dates check him out at Philly purrs
world.com tour slash whatever look check
out Philippe and world.com slash tour
for all shows dates and ticket links
also look out for me and this month I'm
gonna be co-starring or guest hosting or
be a guest star on superstore on NBC
what's America Ferrara I'm I'm in two
more episodes so I don't know if they'll
both come out um in the same month but I
just been gonna email bro to make room
cuz I'm gonna be another episode okay I
should third episode that's what yeah
man so I'm granting yeah man so you know
I gotta keep they give me Hollywood
gives me just enough work to keep my
dental plan that's what I'm talking
about this and what I wanna do man
you know Rodney Dangerfield I heard that
a lot of the old um the old comics who
work they would give their homies a
little spot in a movie brother they can
just keep their dental no sad going
insurance yeah I got a question for you
what's the guy on your t-shirt you know
watching that the guy my t-shirt is Luis
Guzman oh my god fool oh you guys know
you guys made it anybody give it to me
shut up to me that is oh my god
gangbanger bro Oh a Puerto Rican
Aborigine just added to the New York
show bro Luis Guzman yeah I'ma be there
Lower East Side representing so he's
gonna help us out man because we're
trying to put move tickets man so if
anybody out there man spread the
man we need people to go to New York
City we're having a tough time selling
tickets also what's up let me see him a
diamond your flashlight for this we have
uh we have borrow thank you brother
yeah man oh man a fresh new year has
begun and if you're setting new goals
for your business it's extremely
difficult to reach them without the
right people on your team and zip
recruiter has transformed how you can go
about finding them how's the recruiter
is different zip zip recruiter post your
job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards with just one click
then zip recruiter actively looks for
the most qualified candidate and invite
them to an apply no wonder 80% of
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire they even review application
every application to identify top
candidates so you never miss a great
match so something would be lying huh
bro I lied I lied I said I drove a
forklift fool when I get there is a
stand-up forklift oh [ __ ] I will be a
sit-down one foo I knock down a whole
rack you're lying
a little thing that guy brought I think
you want to beat me up it would happen
whoo little by little little by little
he trying to give me the quit bro back
giving me other job like once then he
gave me an axe to go chop down a tree ok
log jammer that's what I mean you know I
never done this right see you think our
there was no zip recruiter back then by
water book find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
our sizes and industries to find the
most qualified
job candidate with immediate results
right now my listeners can post jobs I'm
still procuring for free that's right
free just go to zip recruiter comm /foo
that's zip recruiter comm /foo one more
time zip recruiter comm slash fool I
think model should call him later
cousins
whoa well he hired his uh his nephew
back he's had a funny historia broken
she's to work on HR human research it
through him like super cooler like how
did you zip like I don't you know which
ones were qualified but whether patent I
need you go by their head right no first
we had we had a keyword filter yeah our
job so when emails would come in real
fool I'm done
we had a keyword filter first certain
skills right but then we you just kind
of get a sense of how professional they
are you know from how they how their
resume is format and how it's done now
they could have gone to a resume service
so you know you don't you just but you
choose the ones that look the best first
of all if you've got an email that's
like I remember I remember the funniest
email I remember you have to have a
different email address or something
that's professional or your name or
whatever as your email address I had one
that was her email is big but and sexy
you call her qualified apology it was
big but and sexy as you know computer I
don't know but this was a tech firm that
I was recruiting for so she could have
that email but first that was the first
screening was the the resume then we
call them for a phone screening so if
they had a good phone voice they had you
know they were personable and
well-spoken then we'd bring them in for
an interview if there are flags on the
phone call like they just don't know how
to answer certain things or they can't
formulate a sentence or whatever might
be judo I know computer which I got from
one woman I know computer
I know computer but we had we hired like
this Rosie Perez but no they were no
come on
I do Rosie Perez I'm not gonna do anyway
but no then we bring him in for an
interview in person and then but in
addition to the interview we had to test
them they had to actually make we worked
for I worked I recruited for a
word-processing bunch of word processing
centers and investment banks and law
firms in New York City that was the
first thing then later on when I was
doing permanent staffing I went into I
was Stefan help desk people and IT and
network designers and all these people
so that was a little harder you can't
really test on that you have to go on
referrals and and how they are in the
interview you have to speak the lingo so
but the ones that you'd bring in and
test they were doing like word
processing so they had to create
documents and spreadsheets and
everything from scratch and so then you
could see how they formatted them how
they built them so there really is no
fudging on that test
zip recruiter basically they got rid of
the people who were like out there
chasing out business district for work
hard yeah but also they simplified it
because you don't have to have a
separate software anymore that's at the
workplace to pull in like keywords and
pull in look for resumes online and
because that was a software that you
used to have to buy it first now it's
just a subscription service and they
weed out all the work when I was working
at Wacken hooker securities you were
kind of attempt well you were a staffer
dispatch boy and I one thing all the old
saw board
I think was Christmas Eve or Christmas
Day or New Year's Day one other day
where nobody was working bro I went to
the fires abroad to find out like the
hyeri's man we're talking about man you
look at personnel files yeah no not
personnel they were coming in for that
resumes are the applications bro and man
somebody
go all out man somebody's got came with
videos like a face that is Dwight
Schrute here bro this is work for
security guard you know with a gun at
the jury more we had a lot of like
off-duty police officer LAPD officer
they work for us they were working
lining moonlighting over than the jury
store probably do was like walk in with
a guy with her Jews and then walked out
with him now is there as other jobs
no escort but we always needed those
guys so I'm looking for application some
of these guys bust another ape try to
for three photos bro
and they buy tents bro how he looks and
then one with no t-shirt bro and once I
talked to somebody out don't grab the
jewels
tacticals you know please leave in tools
what everything brought it and I think a
man I'll go through everything that yes
everything is nice
why'd this guy get hired he must be
crazy
he's too crazy that's like that
observant report like you are core yeah
you'd look at some of those things and
just go now this guy's he's highlighting
way too much like military style he
can't be a cop I know like he listed
everything man like like him apart like
everything man like like he was this is
my hobbies bro and pleased I been at the
sniper skills and [ __ ] you do like a
buddy table people never and that's not
appropriate to send or ask for either
you're not supposed to know what the you
got hired by standing mondo video of him
smashing arose with what I hired for
their conditioning companies and the
boss said one thing they have to have
teeth that was his own rule he's off
they can sell I don't care no felonies
and have to have teeth now you're not
supposed to know what they look like
before they come in the door cuz a lot
of people get weeded out would get
weeded out that way not just by looks
but also you could you know without my
first name like his name
Turner sad I don't know about that but
like I think there is profiling when
people look at resumes and stuff and
there is Turner they see certain names
whether it's something like that or you
know an Indian name or Chinese name or
let's you know you know long letter
label little bit of where we never did
chop chop or a dog a mutt episode 7 of
the first season of trouble deadly huh
he's already in prison they got him they
barely got him hey bro Sam how about
that dirty yet politician oh that sneaky
fool that was bringing the shoes in the
first episode the world all good
he's part two and I looked him up in
real life he's always got a job
inside Brooklyn he's always been like
the guy in between the cartels and the
further top advisor huh but he goes you
go this guy he tell the guy later on
there's no way these we're not gonna get
rid of a billion-dollar business
oh hell yeah they're gonna go away he
doesn't no matter who you like oh
there's gonna be new guys but we could
control them we could control them from
getting so high so someone they might
they had a big-ass deal bro with if they
do look they lost cielos I was treating
range supreme for how many years yeah
that a model day yeah for days but I
wasn't should all the dooster like
started being getting too much money
later what happened with him I don't
wanna really he let the he let certain
cartels
get too big yeah and but what happened
was there was only one cartel when he
was done when he finally got locked all
the while I ha and they split up the the
the the [ __ ] the routes and all that
[ __ ]
you know they started you know what is
TJ all actually and I said oh those are
the Arellano félix brothers right
they just changed the name to change the
name bro so we won't get killed yeah
dude it was a dude I think it's a good a
show dog he's a good actor that guy odd
come out of nowhere perfect little
profile too huh oh yeah ever casted him
yeah I gotta watch you they wanting it
and then think goes from Salinas do
because you have like you know Salinas
Presidency say do
that would that ball fool would bond it
was just Felipe Calderon and now you
have pena nieto dude that's a lot of
years though man how much money you
think the little fool that shy used to
shine shoes God bro
nasty nasty bro dude but I had money
isn't that crazy how he set up how he
set up that general dawg
Blanco how when he made up that story he
did it with that reporter lady and he go
kill her yeah that fool was pissed that
he lost his job
hey but he [ __ ] up he hired that
little fool that idiot he was sneaky
since the beginning when they got that a
governor from what I write who how about
when the chopper went all the way to
[ __ ] make that deal with they don't
get with Pablo Escobar I do that was
badass to get balls after about 48 hours
today remember that fool that he knew
when oh yeah yeah that way then he shows
up in narco that guy is he's one of his
chopper here the bidding on a chopper
main sicarios really yeah originally
originally yeah so to know that guy
where that means you're in
yeah and you know was badass dude I
thought they he was a better Pablo than
in narcos they all [ __ ] up Howard a
[ __ ] um when they [ __ ] out mom when
a fool kill everybody their [ __ ] dog
that oh no ha oh yeah it's waiting
eating tortoise blood they just got paid
for that really happened huh oh yeah oh
ha [ __ ] jacked up a thing is people
talk fool
that's high-tech [ __ ] they knew a food
we're at our car yeah you're gonna tell
somebody dude up buddy into something
yeah it's gonna get out but how about
when they kill homeboys family dog but
you know what was more [ __ ] up to me
that chick cheating on his ass start
with that food oh she's stupid ass oh my
god how how [ __ ] how strategic was
that bro to plan it out these are we're
gonna [ __ ] you over we're gonna get a
guy that's gonna make your chick fall in
love with him and later on we're all
gonna get together and move out with you
and your family I'm a poison your kids
throw them over a bridge and then kill
your wife yeah I got that feel good yeah
that's a little CLC a little work on
that his work yeah
yeah good like it was work from mom stop
somebody else
no it's not those brothers those
brothers but that fool always wants a
chapel did he started hating since he
did that 48-hour run of the cocaine in
two days serious
remember when you watch some in Chapel
the show you a little something happen I
read in books so it's really based on
reporters and actual witnesses and
people and I'm confidential informants
it was just all the stuff that uh we
find out after the facts its history
basically now you think I'm Mexico like
a lower in bearer so this is out there
yeah I think so and the DEA I think so
too
even though it dude that cricket D
crooked DEA full they stopped that for
when he's trying to make that 48-hour
run anybody ain't either paint him off
again inside dude all the money a dog
how about the money that got rotted out
and what Amala for millions I didn't
have fifteen stacked in there dude
goddamn dude but yeah it's all was so
fool no crackling noise here we went to
work Happy New Year man we were at you
happy Christmas yeah in this country we
say merry next year somebody tell me
next year I'm buddy tells me we could
say merry now I'm gonna say listen
[ __ ] who in the [ __ ] told you
you can't say merry and bring him to me
it's like a [ __ ] kick his ass my
mother's name I don't know man people
don't know that but our 48 hours of
Christmas movie yeah man it is come stay
happy oh thank you for correcting me
Merry Christmas
what is it in a handbook somewhere Paul
Gleason that's me how was your Christmas
it was good I got everything I got more
sweats it's hard getting hard to find OG
tracks and horrifying audio tracks with
a zipper back zipper but you like you
like it with that design on the chest or
you like the little leaf better that's
what I'm saying like look at the leaf is
cool man I I turned down a bio tracks
because they didn't have a leaf yeah
well I got a I forget that my my blue
tracks to do they believe but yeah
people want the leaf bro at least I find
that it's hard to find the regular pants
cuz I had to get you breakaway still
haven't even found those trios yeah man
Christmas I got um I got I got that and
he got me the a scarf which I want to
wear when it's cold Boulder is cold man
next week in Chicago it's already like
11 or something like that and then it's
getting the colder man we're gonna get
there and I'm bowled in Denver tomorrow
I say we got here we got here in Denver
and a car service bro oh yeah yeah man
what's up fools you wanted what'd you
buy your lady for Christmas makeup gift
certificates you look gift certificate
man I just think it's better that way
that we can go over there and crawling
get whatever you want dude you know it's
cool to get little gifts though but I
mean that we can you know customize your
little uh like it just don't stop
perfume rose nice it's funny guy or
perfume Cologne I want to get these days
the older I get like I want domestic
stuff I want put cooking utensils and
pots and pans and stuff like that and
and I want baths you know products and
bubble baths and stuff but these guys
don't get that for them she's black out
of that hummus rock man needs to be
scraping her heels bro I mean I've never
seen it but I mean not never seen none
never done it but I've seen it I've done
it bro
like once ever the first time I ever
rubbed my heel man bro I could have I
could I was I'm cutting my coat with
liberal disgusting yeah man oh no how
many people really really got tore up on
Year's Eve my New Year's I got pretty
drunk yeah three bottles what you guys
do after boom it took us three hours to
get home oh yeah we left early right
right right we got out we couldn't get
no we had no not just this not just no
signal like no nothing would open no
internet apps wouldn't even open do you
think it does it cuz of that stadium I I
don't know if they were knocking it in
there but you guys had no problem with
it was slow but when we were walking out
I was looking up lift and I was like
well let's find a good place to stop but
there's a lot there I guess but we
didn't know there was a lot so we kept
walking down but everybody's walking
down away from the stadium and then we
know that we couldn't open our lyft app
it just wouldn't open and then we tried
we finally got it open then it wouldn't
find any directions anywhere it wouldn't
even or where we were so we kept walking
down the street but then we noticed a
lot of people were looking at their
phones like like same issue and then not
even on our network somebody was on AT&T
or whatever so we're all at the Wells
Fargo trying to get picked up all these
people and nobody has finally we kept
walking further Felipe's nice was like
will drive you to wherever you want to
go like we took we had her take us to
Boyle Heights no we caught a lift there
but if it hadn't been for them I
wouldn't have taken us forever that was
like an hour how are you
yeah well the real pet we're doing a
girlfriend camera yeah but I was I got a
parking spot on the street so we just
walked over there hopped in the car went
to Chili's ate chilled out and then I
went to Target went to Best Buy and then
like you know we were gonna go to the
big party and then uh you know the
little guy call me let's go to and then
just went to Riverside it's got blasted
dog I was it man
again I was too tired by I've passed out
didn't wake up to those edibles hit you
I guess yeah do they hit me later to
dogs or later huh yeah I had to take a
little nap dude in the car dude
you're talking about the gummy ones yeah
yeah how many did you give your needs oh
you won
[Laughter]
we got these every week we got good
seats we were right by the touchdown you
know by the pole but um the sad thing is
a charger keeps chlorine and every time
they scored the cannon went out right in
front of us here the sherrilyn to my
left ear still [ __ ] up from that
they'd a Robert they Roberts Park Astros
that where the charges draw my food it
was so many Raiders fans bro
ah dude was like a home Raider game it
was like a family reunion for a leery
defense guys who like I really wanted to
keep on sitting down next to you there
were no fights yeah it was pretty chill
there was a lot of argument sighs are
you in it yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] nobody
threw down for how about that that's a
white lady bro oh dude flipped out fool
oh my god dude that [ __ ] was hilarious
her husband stopped her ass dog she's
really Lord she was not ready to sit
next to a bunch of Raider fans oh hell
no but you know she stood a cruisee
showed up who's got a new outfit over
here
paperboy dog oh you know what I got this
out of thrift store
yeah I mean this is importantly and do
it was but no but listen I found them
fooling nobody
I found it I had store brand new sack
same one for twice the price everybody
we have our guest here man all the way
from Montebello on a battle for the
valley no Dom for Montebello done so you
went to Montebello high school my high
school I went to green with elementary
went to my them on about high school now
people need to know your birthday Brody
go to your identity your password why I
sign people decide stuff or they're
always that is different now bro always
like I know when I sign a t-shirt no I
make a f and then I write my name oh
like a printed out yeah cuz the later on
bro people tell you know I'll be
watching too much for SI parla bro I'm
just being you play a crazy one last
night bro I was thinking about hiring a
handyman but now I'm thinking out [ __ ]
daddy the mohawk it kills me within my
house setting checks in my name dude
this pokey handyman bro what happened
what are you do they don't know he
killed them is your signature the same
from your checks to your actual
signature for the people here fans I
don't know this fool of your [ __ ]
sipping out clues dog I mean sometimes
you will do that if they forget to
change it I see people who just do like
[ __ ] like this yeah yeah I've seen that
show his jokes every time we have free
for him for people's day lumber make our
names
[Laughter]
so what happen with the handyman dollar
what's up or bass or default this guy
dared of ko he was dead but I think he
was missing you know but homeowner
yeah homeowner but he kept standing his
daughter's knee his granddaughter's
birthday car with money in it but then
somehow the dollar started noticing that
the car just less than two mental the
tone change bro will start a party with
the mower
yeah so he couldn't [ __ ] keep the
letters going dog yeah nothing to talk
about
no so no no here he was faking his
signature and everything so but it went
from I hope you have a nice birthday
well not to have a good one whatever but
the wife the daughter noticed that it
was different right
so they started investigating bro and
they went to the house search and look
empty but then a cop this [ __ ]
Mexican cop who like [ __ ] human she's
not fat he goes like this like mondo too
he goes out there he goes I went back
could I when I saw the video I noticed
that the the rug was taped to the ground
like if I were to do that my wife would
kill me
you ripped a rug off there was blood dog
and it was a bullet hole and that food
shocked or older and then buried him
under the house under the house under
the house and then we're signing our
living there bro like chilling like it
was like it was a [ __ ] comedy condo
bro and he was sending his checks going
to the ATM but this is how he [ __ ] up
bro he was taking our 6000 from that
fools
checking account and then putting in his
mouth the same day in his account
[ __ ] - yeah so at the end at the end
he said listen man I was hired by
another guy who the conspiracy I was
hired by another guy to take care of
this guy is account and I go but why do
you think the money are - the money on
putting my classical professor pays
bills with my checks
so in the end of would they say [ __ ] all
that dude
they [ __ ] said they're full and
therefore they searched his house he had
a [ __ ] 22 love silencer the same
bullet that went into it didn't match it
don't match so he that guy said that I'm
silencers are banned in in America or
California because they can't trace the
bullet
no more once it leads go that bad for
the ballistics I thought because it was
quiet
in court they're full sin come on fool
so they brought in I'll [ __ ] DLA
[ __ ] and they [ __ ] shaked all
those tabs and it was saliva those
stamps in the cards there was no way I
would have been using the dog and these
are the visa use me so border over here
said I would have pushed a bunch of
water and you know he would sleep with
one eye that no Rosie and you don't
wanna lick the stamps anyway do you know
what there's rat poop on that [ __ ] yeah
that glue used to be made with horse you
will die like you would better just as a
peon see there's a gentleman Z if they
could ever get comedians if there ever
would have pushed shoulder Robin I
sexual harassment this is gonna be
assaulted is a nice shoulder rubs on
waitresses would have better get the law
our next comedian when he's not arrested
with Joey Medina he's the only guy going
through puberty at foot at 55 I'm at the
well Cody did when was cost of Tears
back then really 2000 2002 when I came
yeah yeah yeah I met you where would I
meet you I'll meet you at what a Rick
Martinez shows probably yeah
bowling alley that's right over there in
the downing without who recording over
sets without knowing I know he quit
comedy you know that right really yeah
well last time I seen him but a year ago
he's telling me he was on that row
really he was about to quit yeah who did
it who will became a born-again
Christian no Sean dizzle are you serious
by the way Sunday's it was the original
Chicanos Kings of Comedy right with all
this show Chicano Kings of Comedy he's
the one abroad I'm Frankie quinones when
I first met him I think she might not
have been I mean she was on Wednesday
night and San Jose right yeah man and
there were a troubles upon him a quick
Martinez Oh bro they were I should run
into him a lot at work Quixote The Laugh
Factory
yeah and this is like I started and I
started I attempted to do count over
seemed like when you got started do when
I it was there's not that many comedians
that number one now there's a gazillion
of them and I've just started a [ __ ]
I live no no this is 97 when I started
97 I started it like 97 yeah I'm not
sure I went to to the Open Mic scene
let's go to wallow le kappa remember
that place that go to the [ __ ] yeah
le cabaret cabaret before the next owner
owned it huh I don't know I just
remember doing an open mic there one
time we got to know the alley cabaret
was almost like flappers yeah it's like
flappers but they had they had a bar
comedy show and had a main room that was
empty and so then I did yeah I did
freakin the show that Jeff Kurr sees to
do back in the day which was ones that
dock hey that was about a 50,000 I
wouldn't know Safari bar
yeah the first time I came out to LA
yeah he stopped that show the the week
before cuz no goods on go they go just
closed a fiery bar bro cuz I I do double
to them and see a show and I how can I
get started comedy I mean see you said
you want an autograph or not [ __ ] no
he was right behind him dude really my
homie Justin feels with me [ __ ] that
[ __ ] let's go [ __ ] him up
I don't need no problem starting out in
the game dog [ __ ] and they don't know
he's all come back hey what's up bro t
know how me bro hey just go to Safari
Barbara I don't know man he's having a
bad night done you starting to by work
to the safari bar after the after the
devil lost it bro
so so we headed after where we're headed
after had it put had it for a little
while then they probably just appeared
from that place oh that went through I
mean it was always packed on Wednesday
night heard that was the place to be
though yeah I went through but I
couldn't go out with always it like I
have my room oh right yeah you guys had
two rooms up that night right with the
world coyotes and we had daily plan in
there oh I remember the Daily Planet
holy [ __ ] goes way back there the
Denny's no never a mirror a my okay that
was a place that you had to be funny dog
I mean because they'll [ __ ] people
I used to bomb in front of his a high
school friends I'm and do that girl we
suck my [ __ ] that guy though that'll be
Bob but being care goodbye a math
teacher what beauty hey but you know I
know I will eat the bar bar Senate so he
said hey bro yeah I remember back in the
day we used to suck bro but at least you
sucked on your own material I wasn't a
hack [ __ ] it's better to die
with dignity dogs yeah nobody hits do
that [ __ ] I can't even do that shitty
word I did a show with this [ __ ]
at the J spot right it was me chapel
cave spyfu we all bomb for all talking
[ __ ] this [ __ ] gonna go up
there dude
[ __ ] Jay was there that I saw come
here little [ __ ] you can't be
going up there with theories you good
[ __ ] boo you died out he points
at me duh I don't know what the [ __ ] you
did but you did something and I'm gonna
watch out there now that will give me a
sweater dog
besides all you got potential because
James Poole started it was a little slow
right okay I've met Jay Anthony Brown on
the phone and um when I was when I was
under armed that show that's the silicon
is Jo fly Jacque okay Tom Joyner yeah
Coco so he was a co-host and when I
wasn't doing the interview and Jo did
you brownie you know Philippe Philippe
imagine wanna seem I've always been a
big fan of you might think you're so
hilarious watch out now I'll thank you
very much man that's much appreciated
and also you're very honest man your
honesty will make me laugh so much one
time you were calling into the armed The
Steve Harvey Show I think I thought you
were calling in some radio station in
our lame a United to point through the
beat and you're turrible the J spot and
I think it was bound for the big boy or
somebody you were talking to and they
were it goes so let's update without a
chance any problem on the J spot man and
so he's cracking every night huh oh man
man that cracking man eating crack you
know I'm here how much I get people out
today
that place is yeah it's a that's too
busy selling suits doing I mean it feels
like a strip club though when you walk
in there oh I did go to that that the
place that was way
yeah gonna cup a bad name a place and it
was and then one night Sheppard was
battling to Salvador's and rabbinate
beat his ass what though some guy goes
they tell them you're a rapper and well
this Homer he does rap to what you call
it fool out
Chapo had nothing for a boy yeah it used
to be next to a dispensary yeah that was
one of the first la dispensaries right
there yeah off of Manchester I have to
compute the J spot was the other room
with definitely not the family rule you
talk about the mixed nuts comedy big
nuts
okay no that's gone comedy Union still
on his legs still it's still wholly not
you know that wasn't covered using the
same thing same order it was but I guess
a guy from exactly went over yeah yeah
every night eat him not tough is it not
finesse with African it was African had
it at the end right there mixed nuts
that's when Betty Menon was doing his
long night together oh no it can't be
together I remember he said makes 9cc
scruncho they're doing his roller derby
that's when he had his girl with him
it's like super tall I say Jesus she was
hot too man Oh shoulder have you see
that this means his hands are like
humongous do for a little guy he's like
he's a little stocking dude you know I
mean like he'll knock you out
he's a little he's a little fullback
hey remember at the ice house bro you
were there and I do was trying to [ __ ]
with you and that drunk [ __ ]
remember there and I was just standing
it was after the shows I mean it was
late dude and then it was the bartender
his friend he was on your face [ __ ] you
come on I was a his [ __ ] did I
remember bro remember yeah I don't know
but all I know he was mad at you and he
want to fight you and I was like this
[ __ ] watch and I was waiting for
him to do something oh [ __ ] I hope flank
right in this pot you know nice I'll
show you who it was Brock who look for
that I remember was that it was the
[ __ ] do is it's all drunk he was
messy about it was like a [ __ ] Middle
Eastern do or some [ __ ] damn Dale yeah
he was like he look like he put him in
Maxim but look Middle Eastern but he was
to say awful and he was I guess jealous
of you you had a good set for zero I
took his cheap probably and that's what
so a man dog right jealous you never see
you see mad and security dog when you go
up there and you destroy and [ __ ]
people want to be all touching yeah the
guys ripped it up but where the women
well it's specially we're when the
wife's desire
yeah yeah like your husband's right
there why are you even flirting with me
like and he's there like I was a fan and
not tonight that let's just get mad too
when the husbands are all into the
community it's opposite like she like he
never gives me that much attention try
writing 45 minutes [ __ ] so man would
you um hello how long you been in comedy
now 30 97 but yeah but you didn't go for
it either that started like I must wind
up on stage one time one time in 94
probably the Oh maybe or will 85 95 35
because Phillip was - yeah it was 95 it
was at though that's your fudge then he
was born that just started getting to 96
yeah III want to say really started at
2002 is one nice cuz I went for 97 to
2000 and then I quit and I was doing
sketch comedy but those three years are
probably not like once a month if that
once every three months you know me I'm
on average those first three years so it
wasn't really light but in 2004 when I
kind of kicked it in gear when I started
like alright here we go let's get it
going that's when I got in the Laugh
Factory guest room it was you know it
wasn't a troupe it was like I was at the
next stage theater or I don't know if
you guys know on La Brea and sunset they
they still offer do free improv every
Monday and they just [ __ ] like hey
you want to join this group yeah all
right cool let's just do it here
you guys have a show in the next five
weeks I I'm down now that's pretty much
it you know I mean like and I just kept
going you know cuz I was like at the
time you know I wasn't feeling comedy I
was going through some [ __ ]
you know so I couldn't be on stage you
know I just wasn't funny how come you
didn't get to music like your dad it
doesn't musician's musician yeah Kevin
his original member
yeah reasonable member and he's on the
first three original albums of Tierra
you know I mean he's the drummer on
there as well you know what I just
didn't feel it dude like I tried its
we're like cut like you would think that
you would like be a bongo player or
something yeah
let me confer Kush abyss ah no that's to
perform yeah yeah
he was just in wins pothead alright
that's a kind of a legend that yeah yeah
they know him because I know murder when
am I your dad did you that perform again
in Christmas dad or they always do that
show yeah he wants to do it at the
holidays it's I wanna Bello it was the
Marbella win they still do it there I
think so menudo remember you did it you
did it right yeah and I did the
following year it was me remember I did
it man and well hey bro showed the G
thang bro but the G thang
Oh Rajee thing become the bomb hey bro
hey I got a seat April I said I just did
a show with you last week I didn't see
you bro I was on right before you I
didn't see you bro like come on Doc you
know me yes for a tip from you yeah when
are you doing the [ __ ] room or
memorize something bro
I gotta see a tape this is a book show
it's the [ __ ] Club I'm saying like
come on relax it actually on top of all
the other stuff you did to his
contemporaries dude you's a dick to
[ __ ] us dawg
but for the dick you forget I don't like
that's the best story I have real quick
cello's bro different s caval have
booked me for Chicago and Ernie G right
to do the show out in like the South Bay
so there are we're all waiting a good
that's it yeah Wilmington DFW here W
yeah it outdoors no no oh that's all you
did the one the harbor yeah and the
harbor yeah we have to fight every time
I did that [ __ ] yeah yeah and so
freaking like we're all there and
Gilbert Gilbert's hosting so alright I
was going out first
I don't know me you've all go off please
probably you're me alright cool cuz
probably Kearney G's in the headline so
we're waiting and give our audience your
first
is Ernie Jesus uh what it is eating any
kind of et yes Bert he was here and he
still trying to sell that old CD is from
forever and so you went up stay on stage
of course he did okay but still would
it's dumped him the fact that he was
going on first I mean me and [ __ ] if I
were like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] sorry how do you guys do though
how we did good so if I could did good -
it's funny doc but it kind of he started
tapering down towards the end of his set
yeah like a big ass dancing yeah doing
the same jokes over and over again
though that recently that was like
[ __ ] two three years ago are you
serious
let motivational speaker right but I
guess that gives retards was coming back
into the real was that growing up back
growing up you know you'd that being a
big musician who was always touring
right he's always touring so he always
gone he's always gone so I was partying
little kid yeah yeah boy he was no like
he was gone from when I was always
somebody that'll tell you a man don't do
this but yeah yeah my mom but I used to
come home me you know me it's a
combination but I didn't start smoking
Wow no no no no no my dad got me high at
seven actually [ __ ] crazy
although dog gave it to me were staring
at shake it no I was no you laid on the
[ __ ] couch smoke you know just came
out the bathroom he goes hey Robbie
wanna hear I'm like huh I don't smoke
he's like yeah I know you don't smoke I
was like what the [ __ ]
and then he's like here I won't tell you
mom was like alright
took a few hits and then you realize
where you're just did he freaked the
[ __ ] out oh [ __ ]
alright go go go and I he like holy [ __ ]
like what am i doing my [ __ ] kid I
mean history
take tonight two or three and he was
like take it in I think he was coach me
when he realized it when the when I went
Oh shitty [ __ ] actually inhaled it
you know I mean cuz normally when you
first hit you're like you're trying to
swallow are you know not a smoker you
know that's exactly what a night no I
think you taught me that most another
huge entire bro here I think so
[ __ ] yeah seven Mike in like um
it's pretty hot like some dad's a lot or
like that you know like you're like five
they'll give you a little beer Jamie a
little sip huh did let you watch you
walk around not buzz are you with the
killers chuckle yeah I remember um you
know Eric my dad will you put his finger
to kill like what I did rub it up my
little toothache yeah I know my lil bro
making oh my mom I remember he tells me
that I [ __ ] went outside and played
and then I read the refrigerator and I
thought sleep there's pretty much what
happened he's dealing good [ __ ]
it was stressed out [ __ ] blood
yeah but back then it was weed though
wasn't there was many buds like it was
yeah it was like super long sticks in
shape so you do marijuana it severed how
do you do that um like later are in a
year that made you feel like a man or
you feel cooler than the kid
no I just oh yeah it did and when I was
in eighth grade because I went to a high
school party and my cousins took me and
so I walked into the back and this dude
from high Z was Freddy Canales I
remember he was like hey what's up
Robert
it was so Freddy and he passed me with a
joint cuz he knew I had smoked so he was
like and all the other high schools like
what's a kid to is it now he's cool when
I'm going yeah I'm cool man yeah he's
got super [ __ ] I'm not a little boy am i
man yeah I'm a [ __ ] with that 12 now
yeah
23 years old never I was so [ __ ]
highs I saw some chick sitting there
with a fat asses like guys want to touch
it
I was like 12 that's when the little
grabbing started I'm a freshman of
course I was lying my age you know I
mean but for whatever you were 12 and
she was it was like a saint a senior in
high school or some [ __ ] she was a woman
yeah I was hoping so so Jerry like so
keep on when you start doing like
hardcore drugs 18 damn PCP
speed fogs they speed hit hard in
Montebello I don't know I was in college
my god Carly we're at and would be right
here in Burbank with the Woodbury right
within a private the private paper be
very pissed I know I'm pissed ox I'm
peeing for the [ __ ] 40,000 dollars later
before you majoring in architecture yeah
I was an architect and then all of a
sudden I got the acting bug and that's
it is over
yeah like that yeah the first time I did
it was my roommates we did uh he had
some speed I've never done anything like
that he's AI got speed bronze like
really what is this what do we do beast
or anything all right well split it up
and we split it up three ways three of
us and their lines were about that look
yeah I sort of got that long about that
thick dog my fright face cuz I did all
one nostril was in pain do my eyes
everything wasn't hurting
of course my nose water I didn't sleep
for like two days whose eggs bro yeah
for two days I was up there just like
that's the word that that happens in
college more than like yeah you're gonna
get exposed to speed yeah a lot of
people and then a first one did coke all
that I was yawning and sleepy I fell
asleep on it
- addict oh yeah were you hooked on any
other drugs I just tried it and there I
never had an addictive personality I
just except for a weed that's the only
thing I'm addicted to right now that's
the only that can't break that [ __ ]
habit fell in love at seven though you
know but that's the one that's more
because my like go we're just anyway no
good we your level your love different
than your yeah exactly I got a have I do
once a man went to Texas hassle I did
the know the one down in Laredo and
McAllen the [ __ ] Wild West Comedy
Club ya know that theater the [ __ ]
theater all for Superman you know I'm
talking about the one in McAllen they're
super yeah Mario sellers oh yeah yeah
every Horta yeah right yeah a little
boat for the eight ball of coke in his
arm
so I [ __ ] he got me some wheels I got
you a dime I know it comes back [ __ ]
yeah a big-ass bag of black horrible
happen to be the same truth about the
same shake how's our Houston bro with
[ __ ] um it was mondo mondo Casillas on
birthday week you were twenty forty
broke morning I was the band
I was a baby anyways I was a week the
Texas but the Houston Texas premiered at
the stadium they were not even playing
at the original state and they were
playing at the Texas Stadium
so they're stator hasn't been built and
gay bro Oh Gabriel he went to go fluffy
want to go asked like I guess the guy
who drove us to get us weed he goes how
much you need man wash three of us so a
lot you know how most cars and I say wow
60 bucks would be enough so I get a 460
do that folk came back with too much
weed and when it was like that's the
most ever got 460 and now I know when
people tell me I'll bring you up at 60
I'll say nah man just bring me a little
sick
there was like oh I wasn't an ounce dude
of all stress Oh straight-up Reggie yes
stay rolling fat-ass one bro I gained 15
pounds that we eating there mondo
hitting last year bro I think a little L
just got throat cancer that we see what
I do just to get rid of the tattoo what
I was doing I was growing fat ik same
thing fat bomber joints and then
whatever fell out went off into the
trash can
you know usually want to save the the
wrath in the trash can and smoke half of
it in the trash can and then roll
another one same [ __ ] oh it's much
changed move days I only had [ __ ] one
week to smoke Oh [ __ ] a lot of weed am
i I'm not gonna finish all this [ __ ] is
this your throat hurts
you got a headache it's just it was
disgusting poison by paranoid [ __ ] man
I heard I'm you want to go do you want
to go do the demos comedy club bro in
Corpus oh yeah you drove I draw any
manner yeah oh is that like terrible
take us on a trip wow man this would be
a comedy club in Corpus Christi Texas
there was an abandoned martini film the
water get in there the whole bar was
closed except the comedy club they come
in a food court
yeah and his [ __ ] food court had a
boat had a [ __ ] skiing ring and it's
mine i baptize and if you go right down
the street there's the brandy more
[ __ ] nice a huge huge yeah so [ __ ]
mean bad comedy club offer plenty of
parking free parking a [ __ ] John
Roman hey you learn about people you
know me and telling me one thing I serve
about Benny man and the day that guy can
talk you know me that boy got some story
entirely bro with my story I said them
Rahul if you wrote a movie you put you
give the extras like hey this is my this
is my impersonation of any minute I'm
right back it sounds tough but we got a
1 on a date you like a penis oh yeah hey
doggy so sorry I wanted a right so so
get this girl right so she called me
right it was like 6:30 morning right so
you call me and say he was out on a date
yeah we're going to date oh sorry
Japanese y'all reckon we gonna report so
I'm ready for working I mean so there I
am
push my hand man I got too much lend my
hairbrush so okay cool so I get to work
you know minutes left I'm a I'm a my
water forever whatever girl tell
whatever to the [ __ ] date is all yeah
I'm gonna get there okay so I'm like
holy [ __ ] dude play by play he started
at 6:30 in the morning and you went what
time to go to day 10 o'clock at night
like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah you
were just you get into the day cops get
to the date
then I noticed we went grocery shopping
oh my god the bar had blue eyes blue
eyes it was crazy I want I blue eyes I
wish I blue eyes you know and then I
started noticing when he when he does
this comedy like he always likes to add
you know he breaks the fourth wall you
do the crowd work he likes to ask like
two questions asks two at the same time
oh all the time but okay how old are you
what's your favorite color hey dog
what's your name hey first time here's
what kinda car you have like what the
[ __ ] let me answer the first one first
you know line em up you drove with how
many I was it take to get to [ __ ] me Joe
it was 24 hours great no listen we kept
shifting back in row a boat or dock hey
I don't way back I hit a [ __ ] coyote
dog
yeah it was a baby one you can tell some
small
I'd always was that wet two or three in
the morning just a Pete was my shift and
I'm driving 90 miles an hour on the 10
on my [ __ ] home you know I mean and
Austin I see this white dog fruit I
don't know boom
and what Benny wakes up the [ __ ] happen
you know coyote [ __ ] you stop [ __ ] no
dude I'm not gonna [ __ ] swerve him I
mean oh yeah this mean that's the worst
thing people do is work not to hit an
animal and then [ __ ] yeah you know
like and then you're done lose control
on the sides of rock right yeah it's
really funny unit oh no ma'am what
happened it well I was Joe right you
know I got a row game right so I drove
from LA here and you pick me up
I've never heard anybody do depression
of that then of course who had a painful
the [ __ ] bumper I did dog so all my
money went to the [ __ ] bumper so your
car his car his car 50 bucks
I'd make you pay - now I know wait just
pay for your hotel yeah he pay for gas I
think so fly cuz I think I was I would
only make 150 bucks on the deal he was
making 300 he didn't pay for it
Jeff wasn't paying for travel yeah oh it
was like cheese yeah really cheap budget
but at the time you later before you own
that Club I went over there they flew me
out and um I did like fried Thursday
through Saturday
brother I'll do before Last Comic
Standing
- and it was packed people showed up
yeah and then [ __ ] like the the
statue or what's the name Selena yeah ro
let's get back to a corporate Chris
let's talk about that shitty hotel you
stood it
oh the we saw that the [ __ ] no we
start the red [ __ ] the Red Roof Red
Roof Inn yeah I thought you stood at the
Bayfront in where he stood why families
are living in there dude and the most
roaches I have ever seen was [ __ ]
infested ah bro he opened up disgusting
you open up a lock I gave you sleep I
never took the sheets off dude and then
I would just basically just go in there
to sleep I never unzipped my uh my
luggage my luggage and unless I needed
something it was [ __ ] disgusting you
know what the trickiest thing was I
[ __ ] up in a body bag over these
[ __ ] roaches did not come out - two
days dog they like psych me out
and I seen one roach and then another
roach and then I start looking around
with I was like dude this place is
[ __ ] infested and I was like dick you
like I know if you have roaches I walk
into your pad I can smell em for these
[ __ ] I don't know if they had
right guard or something dog that even
smelled like regular roaches dog smell
like it smells like a really damp ish
pungent smell I know the raw smell -
yeah it's almost like a step below mold
ah you know like bad fruit it just
really it's subtle it's kind of like
like a like a old piece of wood smashed
with root beer and a marshmallow
definitely something like that it's a
peculiar smell if you know what it is
you know what it is kind of like bark
yeah it's it's wet work like you know
just damp like that's right when I used
to move and live in apartments the first
thing I would do is go to the kitchen
open up the drawers and look in the very
back oh that's how you have to do it
rotten wet clothes laundry dude why do
they smell like that I have no idea I
think just how they're built they're
made and I think where they actually
like to like congregate and like nest
there must be all over their hotel are
you Aurora
are you draught specialist 2001 a year
before I met you big time oh you did
right man so man what was that like dude
like man you were the person for 24
hours Pro driving yeah it wasn't you
guys must've been like at least first
you are excited huh then it was like
three hours of silence well we know cuz
he doesn't [ __ ] smoke tried no weed I
was like yeah we know I did that's yeah
every time we stop I step outside I'd
smoke and I get back in the car yeah
yeah gonna drive past your mind huh yeah
I lost my [ __ ] mind you have to share
a room
I think we did there's no escape yeah we
had to share a room
yeah we had a [ __ ] share a room and
he did an hour and a half I think so
there
you do our to have easi there that was
just one story [ __ ] the road I mean
you know the longer you go for a gig as
long as I drove for a [ __ ] gig 24
hours yeah yeah I mean I've droids
anyone I've driven to like San Diego and
California by myself you know me up
north you know to like pass sacrament
you also uh you know you've worked with
Willie Barcena yeah you taking to the
road took me on the road yeah yes put
the room with him - no no you get your
own room cuz he just wants me his own
room which I'm um I'm okay with that but
he always likes to [ __ ] wrestle dog
yeah I mean what's the grab buoy like
hey Roberts but a couple come on hey
special when he gets drunk and [ __ ] he's
like there he is and you know and he's
grappling his fans do I've seen him
grapple fans like Oh like go back
through the show no like do the mattress
against the wall on sheer know where my
one Jews only wait are they all look
kind of your size though no I think I
always have a theory that he picks guys
who are shorter like Martin Rizzo like
he wants to dominate
mean picks his weight class that he no
stop hanging around before after he
would try to get this is huge for you do
we try we tried but I didn't let him
because he's alright let me get you in
the mood first I'm all I wrestled in
high school MA no we can mutually
wrestle but I'm not gonna let you get
well it's not gonna work then bro and
he's trying to get out for disaster
there's all I know what are you doing
what are you doing so we wouldn't let
him drive got three mil country wouldn't
let him either dog yeah so uh Russell
you wrestled in high school - yeah yeah
cuz I got your ass I one time the
parking lot of wild Cody's yeah yeah it
took a while but wrestled in years yeah
anybody who wants to pride themselves on
being a good wrestler want somebody to
put themselves into no you can't do it
that way yeah you can start off that way
but like
yeah there's no way cuz he wanted to
show you how well that moved work yeah
get the person in the [ __ ] moon do
the ever one time we were [ __ ] in
apasa we literally worse know a San
Antonio
oh we're not the River Center the lol
then with the newer one by the band
Jimmy Rodney airway is you mean a black
guy named Ronnie Rodney no no I mean
Rodney I met that's what I meant what's
his name he's here now and Todd Larsen
little short guy no white dude talk yeah
that's cool yeah he's cool good and so
[ __ ] do we wrestled for like [ __ ]
till 7 [ __ ] morning oh my god dude I
was so I was drunk my rumble so we kept
going and I really look at the quarter
it was seven a year and the Sun was out
dawg what the [ __ ] are we doing do it
and nobody filmed it no no we do have it
on film that's why Richard Chang has it
he has it
people I'm sorry this was our passel
that was our passive driver we'd add the
one in San Antonio I think we've cuz
really doesn't like to fly you doesn't
why not he's a fear of flying I guess
wrestled the plane dog I would rather
[ __ ] fly get their [ __ ] now you
know I mean everywhere I go if I'm I
know I'm gonna take a long flight like
the longest I ever did was like 15 hours
or some [ __ ] like that
were you going I went to I went to
Afghanistan and Qatar Qatar Doha in
Japan so all three times I [ __ ] ate
edible did I crash the [ __ ] out when you
did those shoulders let us know tours to
promote the first one was do gar yeah
yeah Japan I did Japan I don't get okay
now uh yeah it was a quick like four
days and be well yeah we made what
building up better than Corpus Christi
oh hell yeah dog Jimmy we with IDA
kuching myself oh I think that was like
five years ago yeah
and then the so partner that I was find
out and then Doha Qatar I went there
total audience man how much these um I
did an army tour in America and how tell
them how much these troops actually
appreciate they appreciate they tell you
like this I'm a man think of a bring in
California flavor to us yeah especially
miss home yeah they miss home you know I
mean and there's a lot of you know thing
what was Lima would do an Afghan and
Japan would scare me was like the the
military wise bro
oh yeah why fool dude they're like hey
my husband's deported sniper by some guy
who's gonna [ __ ] find me I wonder how
often that happen
what time with marine chick hey me up
and and I think she was talking to mom
or Rodriguez too and she told me that
she was like the cops she talks all the
car you join Medina she was fooling
around with another another staff
sergeant and she was a while her her
husband was deployed somewhere
they were both Marine she and her
husband yeah she was fooling around with
somebody that was in in town and they
one she was telling like should I don't
know what to do either
yeah well you could be court-martialed
though for having an affair well do
Thursday and when I was in camp fostered
through you have your guide right look
at the girl it was a girl for us she's
gonna take you around whenever so we
became friends she started telling me
all the inside school in the officers
lounge dude they [ __ ] with those
little hands at no no no what they do
with these [ __ ] they have
prostitution arraigns going on we're
we're we're in faster can't faster what
what country Japan so what they'll do is
they're like hockey when the guys that
won there was a deployed they put a
broom outside their [ __ ] door
let everybody know it's on the women
yeah to let all the other little by
little time a little 18 year olds
[ __ ] all that exactly you go with her
no for reals doors like
no the body but they put a broom out
they put a broom out because I thought
movie called jump the broom doing this
[ __ ] they let them know like hey you
know come on over
that's crazy walking crazy didn't tell
you guys nothing about that because I
know that I'm I don't want to say his
name but when I wear camera glasses it
was someone the wu-tang twins and
another UFC fighter
they went on tour and in fact that UFC
fighter back home yeah everyone told me
what you were doing really yeah he was
he was getting proposed by all the
chicks and he was doing it and he was
doing it and they found out bro yeah I
didn't do it because I'm scared of my
[ __ ] life because these [ __ ]
are trained to kill but I also meant you
know you could you know good money good
work yeah you know I want to [ __ ] up
this ez cash right as easy cash both
[ __ ] 20-minute sets you're done
awesome easy they're like they left for
everything everything everything on the
tables and [ __ ] you know I mean like
okay I'm [ __ ] amazing
remember Trenchard we'll have it bad
stand or introduce Eamon as incoming
right yeah he's all that how could that
happen that never happens
Wow when I did Afghan when he gave his
life to the Afghanistan that was a weird
one dog because why because well we had
the what happened to me they had an
impromptu shows I don't you ever done
the Oh what I mean that means like
[ __ ] like like hey when do a comedy
show alright so how many people here
four people all right let's do it all
right all right funny I guess we're
doing comedy for four people and you
just do a show right then and there
and it's kind of awkward you know I mean
like there that you kinda Mike no no
that thing you're just forcing it down
their [ __ ] throat so you know I did I
did some jokes and one do happen to you
know his his girls pregnant
and it kind of kind of got awkward for
me I was like alright let's change the
subject there you know thank you have a
good night you know I did [ __ ] get
myself the light I was like [ __ ] that
because if you got became like he I hit
him I hit like you know his nerve like
so he I guess somebody had passed away
whatever and I didn't realize it and I
said something that reminding him and
then the dude his sergeant say hey just
so you know that that really happens
like yeah I figure that's why I kind of
try to change yeah it was kind of weird
like [ __ ] there this is not good you
know to rub his shoulders at the most
sorry who usually got bombed by the
enemy but today's rubber supply rubber
soon Bobby shoot what's up enemy fire
know that we just heard [ __ ] yeah it
was no it was a I was with what's his
name yeah was someone who bomb bro Tim
Tamara Kattan Paul Ogata and oh my god
oh my god god what the [ __ ] he's the one
who booked me too god damn it do girl oh
no the black here light-skinned afro I
was at the Comedy Store [ __ ] Kareem
he's dark he's light-skinned yeah yeah
no dudes like [ __ ] he has two kids to do
the half roll yeah dude he's been doing
comedy for years dude Michael no god
damn it
why am i [ __ ] hate skiing brother with
a half rope he still all used to do
bring your shows at the Comedy Store a
lot
he always did bring your shows for years
until recently obviously the comments
are don't need nobody I'm a broke ass
something Fargas Mason yeah yes Fergus
Mason for you that's not an afro those
are dreads yeah yeah they're short yeah
that time
[Music]
yeah that's him he's the one who booked
it it was cool I mean we had fun pay
well yeah right 250 or 350 AD when you
fly without you fly it on their planes
or regular plane no you fly on Turkish
Airlines from from LA to to kurkistan
and then from kyrgyzstan you fly on
their plane on the military planes into
Afghanistan noise an airplane oh yeah
it's [ __ ] loud c---seventeens and the
c33 c30 [ __ ] it is we just drought to
the plate how those seats huh yeah you
just sit there and [ __ ] put your seat
belt on all them all the guys are there
big-ass [ __ ] jet you see them loading
all their all theirs their stuff you
know I mean some of the guys in that
plane they're not going to the show they
go other places huh yeah they're gonna
get deployed somewhere I don't deal to
the basis of funny would've already
killed dudes great one of the bases bro
is like surrounded by [ __ ] the city
dude it's like right there in the middle
like in the middle dawg you can see the
[ __ ] buildings and everything like
Hawk Down style
oh yeah it's crazy the fort in them and
in Brooklyn is like it's a fort man all
army dudes in it's like tanks then
outside Brooklyn the bridge yeah it's
like that bro and then you have the dude
and the tower just [ __ ] this with
this sniper you're gonna just look and
ready ready and these [ __ ] is a
very few people on this base a small
base - they're all killers so you can
tell they're all [ __ ] got the big ass
how about fooled with beards like
special ops dudes Green Berets and
shooting now you see them true yeah you
see them they're a lot of private you
know I mean do you know Afghanistan
they're much more private than their
[ __ ] soldiers bro
they're like you would see your mom
there die like [ __ ] in the kitchen
like what the [ __ ] some Mexican lady
[ __ ] cooking in the [ __ ] back dawg
like what ruin fly came back from that
to resolve dawg they pay seventy
thousand just to scoop mashed potatoes
on the plate
yeah [ __ ] that yeah well yeah and
they're all Filipino yeah it's all yeah
it's all like it's like you would think
like [ __ ] they're just civilians
disability pay real well man
to make to make up a solely yeah yeah
the military there like there are
military civilian employees yeah there
are subcontractors of the military but
that I had a one on a friend but a woman
I worked with her her husband was laying
cable for AT&T over there he was making
hundred fifty thousand techs free yeah
but the military right across the street
doing the same job making just standard
pay you know and they knew it you know
what they do because yeah that guy
started some dudes he said how they keep
you win they keep dangling care in front
of you to keep you keep going up in the
ranks you know I mean cuz he was about
to retire hey [ __ ] will pay you
morning he's like he's like no no just
I'll be early I'll do the same job but
I'll come back as a contractor so he did
that and he got paid forget ten thousand
a monostable be a UPS brought about but
they have what a thousand days of save
of safety free day nobody got hurt they
all get pizza like is it already in hot
pizza easy there well bro they coming
off sweaty bro yeah man I thought about
you right now like a thousand safety
days like nobody got hurt tons of money
but they get pizza and then it's a happy
bro dude and they got a [ __ ] thing
called a poop on dog what's that dude
they [ __ ] make a big ass reservoir and
all the [ __ ] go all your toilet and it
all goes there and then that takes it a
refill turret and they make bottle of
water and they bother back up and they
you drink that [ __ ] they have poop puns
on on cattle ranches that's what we
shower with in our showers and yeah now
we're sharing with that [ __ ] baby ha
that stuff keeps me up at night the poop
those Armenians French no see if you've
got to use soap as water Oaxaca
apparently
not so what would you been up to now man
you got a name chibi Rose did you go to
auditions
you know I actually gonna I'm gonna
start to this year I had two kids bro I
gotta hook up with them laying low
Mondo's mundo the agency was a Colorado
Rae Alvarado occupier me bro so I said
oh hi to an audition really the one a
pothead bro be with them bro I didn't
like how they run there's no jerk are
there was a bunch of [ __ ] fool
though he [ __ ] he's already casting
before I even cast I broke I sent him
off what the [ __ ] uh he's not gonna know
he's one of those he one of those
light-skinned Mexican dudes - man yeah
yeah I am from Mexico City
yeah [ __ ] I got a show coming up
actually June I'm sorry Jan you area 16
that down Terry Mills improv it's uh
about two weeks from now
yeah - oh you just know I got me I got
Agostino ha I got Rene vaca I have you
seen ID the young kid the new guy he's
pretty funny dude he's only he just
turned 21
you know means you know that excitement
he's just like so you know I mean so he
and to begin when I first met he was
horrible but then I started anyway took
him under my wing and now he's actually
good now he's getting good and hey Doc
any driver no no and then I got maybe a
couple of spots that I'm gonna throw out
there pretty much as me though that's
what you know I'm gonna be doing a
headlining spot
I remember we you should do that show at
the movie theater right yeah it's in a
space sailors Bay have a flat so I did
your show ya know what happened it was
quite what happened right thought you
were gonna make that into a show a
Rachel show well yo dude the [ __ ]
dude I had all these cameras in numerous
I showed up to I had
everything and then with me kid right
yes the do who's he was in charge of
that and I was in charge of the getting
the talent and so I was like hey man
let's cut this [ __ ] let's do it brother
Leslie mess in a space in up it's the
movie theater in Hollywood Boulevard and
it's it's in a heart wherever it didn't
happen I'm buying right yeah right on no
they wouldn't ivar and we were there it
was like well everything we did a
shoulder and far you're doing a theater
yeah it's like a movie theater and they
have a dinner drinks it's you know so I
get the [ __ ] tapes from this guy and
there's nothing on the whoa who did Abby
[ __ ] do know we have lo the camera
just to pick up on jigs ya know we had
months exactly
we had months and months of [ __ ]
filming that we did and like yo we
nothing nothing week after week we did
it for like five one stray dog there's
so much content I was so mad cuz there
are some gold moments there they're like
there's one do remember he he always
bombed so I put him on my show anyways
and he actually did really well so I
gave him he's all I gave him the light
indeed did 10 minutes you guys off young
man [ __ ] three minutes I said we're
doing it no you did 10 no I just do when
you actually do well it actually feels
really short just so you know oh good
point yeah yeah when you rock in like oh
my god was 30 minutes holy [ __ ] 10 you
know I mean that and he's all rules yeah
dude and it was all on tape and
everything like none of that [ __ ] none
of that [ __ ] was recorded and I was so
[ __ ] pissed dude but it was a good
show though we had a lot of celebrities
on that one too it will always come out
on Mondays what's the scene like today
now you know like with the younger
comics and the people you're seeing
right now um I I mean cuz I'm in it
right now with them I feel like I feel
like the comedy is starting to get back
to what it used to be like 4-minute
there was an alternative comedy that
we're pushing for the longest time and
it's just trash you know it's like
everybody was Steven right you know
and it ahead of sweater a mayor yeah
exactly and but see right yeah
but he's funny I wouldn't call him all
call me yeah and but he's nobody that
style and I just come make the call at
the deadpan deadpan everybody I'm
excited to be here as you can tell
everybody's doing that it's gonna be
Byron Bowers yeah and [ __ ] but now I
feel like it's starting to get back to
where they want to see you as a person
you know I mean if the fans want to see
flea purse bars and they wanted to see
Rodrigo they don't want to see [ __ ]
the flavors they see he's a great writer
you know who gives a [ __ ] about that I
know that's true burnout they like
people want to know the water like know
more about you like that when we do is
podcast
people love the personality behind them
you know yeah not [ __ ] like what your
dear story one tiny little time man
don't worry about them or the guy doing
the door you know cuz they're never
gonna be better than one you gotta be
better than you know don't worry about
be charlie better than those guys you
know cuz they're never gonna be better
than you being a beanie I mean you you
know I mean there's a lot of comedic but
there's only one sapota
yeah he'll be gonna be the best about to
ever broke yeah exactly
versus like man got a great joke you
know I [ __ ] you want a real real [ __ ]
but they won't know yeah man
I thought yeah I remember the first time
I smoked weed it was me and my dad
wearing a towel no that [ __ ] I love you
are afraid of talk personal stuff Howard
jiggle I don't want to let it out dog I
don't want to come out and say I'm
actually gay and have a fake boyfriend
you know come on about that but that
might work now though I mean I think
because I think with social media and
stuff people feel like they they get to
know celebrities like there's this level
of access that they didn't have before
like Kevin Hart is doing it right now
he's freaking putting his whole life on
video on Instagram the other day use him
and his son were doing the mittens
boxing like you know I mean this stuff
they would be like okay but people like
that [ __ ] they want to see before people
who want to tell me whether they're a
father
[Laughter]
I've got no kids dog yeah right
your kids oh I got two now bro so you're
married no no you believe with her that
we live together
no well I believe the other three years
now yeah two kids in a three-year period
yeah I take your tire tubes I mean you
know what she wants that my third one
I'm done to me like come on I don't have
to I 2 Z enough don't have three no twos
enough it will be a train I want it I
want to get like right now what my son's
two years nine months my daughter's what
a year in two months so yeah we twins
yeah I mean I'm I'm in there I'm almost
there but I'm in that moment you know
you have to the little hairy oh he's
he's almost three in March and she's
just turned two in mine October these
they grew up together but [ __ ] right now
do you like oh my god again what does
that mean they get into every [ __ ]
thing you have to like you know no don't
touch that come over here okay you can't
hit him enough under for hey like you do
dogs with a [ __ ] newspaper for more
years they can start smoking weed smoke
about what he's seven
all right now never do that keep the
tradition going like dad say about the
grandkids
bring them all wherever joy my grandkids
that's and do what everyone's up to
smoke
I might when I was little his friends be
like hey your kids are there yeah there
are my kids right like oh you don't want
to smoke word inhale and I said I said
never believed in secondhand smoke or
contact high
I never believed in that cuz I never got
a contact high from like as an adult I
never have either debunked yeah but I
look at pictures when I was a kid that
are always always like this
my hobbies close I guess I was high all
the time you know right so what uh what
you got going man are you working on
doing a special or
yeah well actually we're both check it
out I actually got a album I'm putting
it out doesn't mean iTunes very soon the
next few days
as if the Bob shoe fits
that's what it's called and if the Bob
shoe fits wear it
okay yeah the Bob shoe fits and it's
about 30 minutes and we rosa butter yeah
brother Bob shoe yeah I came up shoe and
so freakin if we have iTunes party balls
Johnny walls should I call myself Bob
shoe from mustache just a big mustache
yeah bro so I got that coming out soon
and then I start a podcast about the
podcast everybody just go to pieces
epatha I do actually is so funny of a
podcast so I like ice do a podcast like
10 12 years ago I don't you were really
right no like [ __ ] me and my buddy
Tony from 20-month is Tony yeah bro how
are you remember we did that show yes in
Burbank him with Cisco yes or bagging on
we got all mad remember did you really
yeah so yeah now it's like popular now
it's weird
it wasn't Pablo no it is now it is how
is Tony Montana good he's he's good you
know he's his back is given out of him
though dude [ __ ] are you doing dude
start off a reto anywhere I he used to
do like that old radio station back on
by Channel five moment that was warned
that was purely i it was like remember
the old channel 5 station on Sunset it
was
a little radio spot right there I was
like dingy it was and he used to do it
they're like way back in the day and
with the same boys I think so
and I used to play used to do like how
you used to do like hey Tony Montana you
go back and forth do that however when I
would I did a show with um remember I
will all [ __ ] up the gene pompa taping
in downtown LA oh yeah I remember that
and you showed up with broham yeah I
call a Brougham he always a Brougham
that's oh Lisa look at Lisa bro have you
[Laughter]
[Music]
caught him bro or something and then he
said ham bro to the dance or whatever
smoking weed Icehouse he didn't make any
sense the words he was saying together
we always caught him bro him hilarious
his real name was Jose but he shut it
down there you know me and now they
relocate somewhere else so now he has
his own podcast set up at his house now
you know I mean he has this basically
like set up like this so he's gonna
start doing it and you know I'm gonna
start doing a podcast again but I gotta
find a spot where I know it could be
central where people would actually show
up at my house man yes I can but like
walk over the recorder and just do it
somewhere quietly somewhere I think you
could do it before you depart our
podcast I would just do it before or
after your shows or I always thought it
would be good to have like a parking-lot
podcast you know everybody congregates
in the parking lot anyway yeah chess but
back and then you could just like have a
mic between you know either have a mics
or one central mic that you can kind of
put on the car or whatever yeah I have
the zoom
zoom h4n one of those some thing is yeah
are you it's one thing I own I say about
comedy is like no matter how famous you
get you always still parked by the
dumpster you notice that every [ __ ]
con we park in the back by a space and I
can tear you [ __ ] stinks right there
Riaan crazy i sniffing a juice hey do
you smoke in the green room huh really
occasionally and once some of you I went
with morning show you were in the room
smaller oh you know I gotta find
yourselves and also do the part can with
somebody that knows a lot a lot of
computer skills I know you really need
your guy you need a guy that wants to be
in the party yeah a lady
gillo lutely sia or lisa i will try to
get as much podcast i thought as much as
you can like maybe this podcast and then
George Perez stories and hey Marty
Moreno podcast and then by the time you
do the fourth podcast I would have your
podcast already ready to rock because
now you've got my listeners you got your
Perez listeners you got Marty Moreno
listeners so now you know by that time
you have a podcast ready to rock good
people want to listen to more yeah hold
on to like five or so yeah okay and then
a podcast which is your dad bro about
the podcast about this to shoes don't
fit I have some segments where you're
dead I always wanted to have your dad on
every once in awhile to do like a
weather report cuz you always talked
about how you wanted to be a weatherman
you know
but this happen let's have your dad have
your dad like step in with one thing you
know that you go to him over before
every time yeah he doesn't like new
music that's the only funny though new
track in his review it's not music they
don't even play instruments it's all
digital what's up fool what's up mega
yeah man podcast yeah episodes up so
check it out go to my Instagram link
somebody out this week
Alfred Robles Doug no return roll
together all the time remember that man
throw up together bro yes grew up
together
throw up together watch the YouTube were
so full game recession prices that he
only ticket nom only outfit now huh I
guess what's the name was over there
Ricky chairs your man I couldn't get no
gigs absolutely man about Martine bro
um I think you put the Mexico with those
fools there you go in a [ __ ] yeah dude
I'll be at the brave improv January 16th
are you see people Yemen your so when
Ontario January 16th January 16 coach
Acosta pardon your room Brahe improv
same day Tuesday MN support diversity
will do Taurus
you'll be Umbria I'm gonna be Ontario
Terry Mills more people check them out
if you want to go blaze with a pot I
just mean what about that stinky
dumpster was your tickets for sale yeah
the take a I have a hammer surely there
are timber us come on people [ __ ] 10
bucks yeah if you should be there man
have a [ __ ] free tickets I have a
promo code okay Bob shoe if you guys
typing the promo code always save you
say one word Bob shoes obviously one
word I don't know my people like that
bout you have a part of a bob to you
know your middle name he pops [ __ ] you
Ladislav Oh
okay you [ __ ] your name is Laurie yeah
where you from keep that I'm good
Ontario improv Oh
Ladislav Oh
it's a it's a low it's actually Slavic
whoa from Spain so [ __ ] crazy
so you mix my grandmother was uh was
Basque my dad's mom was Basque explain
the little little sighs well short yeah
[Music]
yeah real real my schools are like small
and they're thick yeah my uncle's like
that and I'm like big little heads yeah
percent they they resisted the Spanish
dog so he's still good yeah still
resilient people before though I want to
get during the pen is big basket in
Bakersfield yeah
dairy farms back there there were a
bunch of dairy farmers they're butchers
- oh yeah so there's another job you
could do broke which is yeah I already
got the Hat hey what's up fool we got
Bobby Shu here
Bobby Chumash oh yeah from Montebello to
the valley
Lisa Esparza Aaron in the wielder steel
rod real toy here with a young man MN
and what's up food this weekend you know
where we at don't forget man zip
recruiters if you want to hire somebody
or start a business go through zip
recruiters calm and use zip recruiters
/foo and they won't even charge you
other than that man Happy New Year man
for our friend
we don't know the words to the song for
Oleg's I